for more on a host of topics from
Capitol Hill I'm joined by Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell senator
thanks for being here a little bit
that's special or want to talk about the
Brett Kavanaugh hearings and other
things first I want to ask you about
this anonymous op-ed in the New York
Times titled I'm part of the resistance
inside the Trump administration said to
be a senior Trump administration
official adding quote in this op-ed it
may be cold comfort in this chaotic era
but Americans should know that there are
adults in the room we fully recognize
what is happening and we are trying to
do what's right even when Donald Trump
won't your thoughts on this well I had
not seen this piece until your set up at
the beginning of this show so therefore
I really have nothing to say about it
other than I think it's important to the
American people to know if you're one of
the American people who were
right-of-center it's been an
extraordinarily productive Congress from
Supreme Court justices circuit judges
regulatory changes tax reform we've had
an extraordinarily accomplished Congress
and that's what our meeting on the white
house was about finishing up this year's
fiscal year business right and you
didn't meet with the president today
with House Speaker Paul Ryan this op-ed
suggests that despite his leadership
style these successes are happening do
you agree with that it's been a good
team yeah the president has been
interested in the things that we wanted
to pursue we've been on the same
wavelength on all of those issues taxes
regulations Supreme Court justices
circuit judges all of those issues we've
been in the same place he signed him
into law and I said if you know if
you're an American out there who prefers
the country right-of-center there hadn't
been a better Congress in the time I've
been in the Senate his attitude today I
mean it was in the wake of obviously the
Bob Woodward book and his reaction to
that then you had this anonymous op-ed
your interaction today yeah we were
talking about finishing the people's
business before the end of the fiscal
year we have to recompensed reports on
appropriation bills sounds may be boring
to your audience but if nine out of 12
of those are signed into law before the
end of September that will not have
happened
since 1997 over 20 years ago completing
a farm bill that America in general is
in good shape
agricultural America is not and we're in
intent on finishing this farm bill
getting its son before the farm bill
expires at the end of September those
are the things that we were focusing on
last thing on this are you worried that
there are people inside this
administration that are essentially
trying to bring this president down look
my job is to try to achieve as much for
the American people as I can
you know these Republican governments
don't come along very often not many
Americans know this we can go back a
hundred years only twenty of the hundred
years did the Republican Party have the
white house the House and Senate at the
same time we don't want to squander that
opportunity I think we've done a lot for
the American people and we're going to
do a lot more before the end of the year
I don't want to belabor this point so
move on to today there was an effort by
your counterpart Senator Schumer to kind
of slow things up on this Kavanagh
hearing a tickle ISM the Republican
majority is deliberately obstructing the
Senate's constitutional duty to fairly
and thoroughly conduct and advise and
consent powers so order in the chamber
as a result we will not consent to
business as usual on the Senate floor
today so not to get too much in the
weeds but explain that was what he was
trying to do is to shut down the
Judiciary Committee hearing we simply
adjourned the Senate to prevent him from
doing that you've seen the antics in
committee your station is but your
network has been carrying it all the
hooting and hollering and misbehavior
but none of that's going to make any
difference the president has nominated
an all-star I went to law school but I
wasn't much of a lawyer but I can
recognize a great lawyer when I see one
and Brett Kavanaugh is a great lawyer
he's going to be confirmed he's going to
be confirmed before the end of September
and beyond the court when it starts its
next session the first Monday in October
senator Schumer's point the calm the
complaint really is about this the
documents that have been upheld some
came out late 42,000 some have fall
under executive privilege from the bush
Shipman
raishin response to that complaint well
more paper has been produced for this
nominee than any nominee in history we
have 12 years of decisions on the DC
circuit which are directly related to
his nomination every one of these people
screaming about getting more papers have
already announced they're going to vote
against him what else do they need to
know they're already against them so
this is a smokescreen you know when you
hear people arguing about process you
know they've got nothing else and with
Brett Kavanaugh there's really no good
argument not to confirm it you complain
though about the Democratic tactics
pushing back against Cavanaugh but but
what about Merrick garland and wouldn't
you have thrown a fit if Democrats
treated a GOP nominee the way you
treated Garland
look I was quoting Joe Biden in 1992 who
said if a vacancy occurred in the middle
of the presidential election they
wouldn't fill it Democratic Senate
Republican President Chuck Schumer and
Harry Reid said eighteen months before
the end of the Bush years if a vacancy
occurred the presidential year they
wouldn't fill it I knew if the shoes on
the other foot and we had a vacancy
nominating a Republican president to a
Democratic Senate in the middle of a
presidential election year they wouldn't
fill it listen that was simply not going
to happen I said the American people are
weigh in on this lifetime appointment
and whoever they chose and most people
time I made that call thought it was
going to be Hillary Clinton whoever was
being elected in the middle of that year
ought to make that decision that's what
happened a Democrat lost you kept the
Senate in session for part of August to
handle spending bills at the President's
request you made the most progress as
you mentioned on spending bills in 20
plus years why wouldn't the president
torch this up because there's no money
for a wall I mean is that still a
possibility that this thing all comes
crashing to a halt
no the nine bills that we're going to
put on his desk before the end of
September which is the end of the fiscal
year deal with other substance but it
also ninety percent of the federal
budget will have been a
before the end of the fiscal year and
she pointed out that hadn't happened
since 1997 we still are in favor of the
wall we still want to get funding for
the wall but we think the best time to
have that discussion is after the
election this is the Fox News Alert
President Donald Trump not finished
commenting on the New York Times
anonymous op-ed he made some statements
earlier but now just tweeting one word
with a question mark
treason obviously referring to whoever
wrote that op-ed we're here with the
Senate Majority Leader treason I don't
have any observation to make on this
episode but last thing I mean for
someone to write and to be quoted in Bob
Woodward's book and and to then write
someone else perhaps the root of the
problem is the president's a morality is
that a problem for this administration
look I would like the American people to
judge the results that we've achieved in
the last two years and we're not through
and I'd like to focus on our
accomplishments of which I think there
are an enormous number no chance
government shutdown no chance of a
government shutdown zero zero in March
the president threatened not to sign the
Amon anonymous bill at the last minute
even though he had negotiated it do you
worry that you may have an agreement on
government spending and then poof you
don't know I don't worry about that we
had a good discussion today I expect him
to sign these nine bills into law that
will fund 90 percent of the government
for the first time in twenty years
before the end of the fiscal year and
then I expect us to do a short-term
continuing resolution for the balance of
the funding and then have the discussion
about how to fund the wall after the
election has the ship sailed on repeal
and replace Obamacare now you have
Senator John Jon Kyl in the position of
of the late Senator John McCain who
obviously voted no on that senator Kyl
perhaps would vote yes is repealing the
place that ship gone for this year
for this Congress it would be difficult
to achieve I think whether we can
achieve it later depends upon the
results this fall and the American
people have a chance to decide what kind
of Congress they want to have going into
the next two years
what are Republicans running on it
doesn't seem a totally unified message
is there one well I think the economy I
mean it's a red-hot economy I think the
policies of this administration and
Congress have made a huge difference
whether it's a tax reform or regulatory
relief the country is booming these are
record numbers that we're producing on
unemployment on growth that makes a huge
difference in the lives of people all
across our nation and that's a result of
this Republican government so we think
we have plenty to run on not to mention
the fact that we're transforming the
courts to Supreme Court justices
twenty-six new circuit judges making a
difference in the lives of every
litigant in the country when they go to
court the president has not been shy
about talking out and tweeting out about
his Attorney General Jeff Sessions who
you know very well he's been very
aggressive in recent days on that front
the vice president just today was asked
about it and he said this quote I hold
jeff Sessions in the highest regard I
appreciate his service to the nation so
are you with vice president pants or
president Trump on this I can speak for
myself I'm a big supporter of Jeff
Sessions I think he's done a good job
and I hope he stays right where he is
you think he will
we'll find out we just finished the
memorial services obviously for John
McCain tell us about your last
conversation with Senator McCain and
your emotions as this week came to an
end I went out to see him in May and we
had an opportunity to relive old battles
we were on the opposite sides of many
many issues and then on the same side of
others and I was pleased I had a chance
to say goodbye John loved a good fight
and I did too and we had a pretty big
one that went on for ten years and ended
up in the Supreme Court we expressed our
love for each other that's campaign
finance obviously yeah a love for each
other and and it was a perfect way to
say goodbye so wrapping this up spending
forum bill opioid abuse prevention FAA
reauthorization opioids I think we're
very close to having another strong
bipartisan opioid bill will get FAA
reauthorized again it's a steady stream
of accomplishments in this Congress
senator will continue to follow we
appreciate your time thanks